مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم كانت ولا زالت
القضيه الفلسطينيه من القضاء الشائكه في
العالم العربيه وقضيه من القضايا التي
اثارت اهتمام الاداره الامريكيه لكن كيف
توازن واشنطن اليوم في علاقتها بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وما هي الرؤيه
الامريكيه للمرحله المقبله
محاورنا حول الاجابه عنها ما هذه عمر
الممثل الخاص رئيس لشؤون الفلسطينيه اهلا
بك على
ما هي الرساله التي تحملها من الرئيس الى
الفلسطينيين
وتتهزن ينادين عائله
الولايات المتحده
ان الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين يستحقون معا
في العيش بسلام
وحريه والامن والازدهار
والعداله وهو يواصل اعتقاده ان افضل
الحلول هو حل دولتين وفقا حدود 67 في
ايطاليا اتفاق مشترك
لكن هناك بعض الاصوات الفلسطينيه يعني
التي تطالب بالحقوق لشعبين متساويين هل
يمكن ان يتم ذلك همم قريبا واين انتم من
هذا الطرح
هذه السنه
الاسرائيليين والفل الفلسطينيين يستحقون
على قدم المساواه العيش في امان وسلام
والحريه والاجتهاد وهذا من واصل العمل
عليه
وبخير ده كنا واضحين ان اين نتيجه اين
نتيجه متفاضه عليها ينبغي ان تؤمن
المساواه بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
محصوره بماذا
سيد عامر
وتعزيز العلاقات بين الشعبين الامريكي
والفلسطيني
هذه العلاقات وتمتينيها لتكون اكثر
انتاجيه واثمارا للشعب الفلسطيني والشعب
الامريكي
الرئيس الفلسطيني
لوح بالانسحابنا الاتفاقيات مع اسرائيل
وطالب بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
بالاعتذار والتعويض للشعب الفلسطيني عن
وعد بلفور ما تعليقكم على ذلك
يعني اي لونها بني كامل
في المحاولات برفع مستوى المعيشه
الفلسطينيه لتصير على مستوى معيشه
اسرائيليين ومنذ بدايه
المليون دولار اكثر من 600 مليون منها
ذهبت لي وكالتي الاونروا
[موسيقى]
همم لرفع مستوى المعيش
عمليه السلام لان تتم وهي وجود المستوطنات
التي يعني ما فتئت يعني تتكاثر كيف يمكن
ان توفر الامن والحمايه لهؤلاء
الفلسطينيين وايضا كيف يمكن ان توفرون
الامكانيه التواصلهم مع بعضهم البعض خاصه
ان هناك الضفه و غزه يعني بعائدتين ومقطعه
الاوصال فلسطين
امم لك وينك
[موسيقى]
البحث في
حل الدولتين هل ستدعمونا فلسطين للحصول
على عدويه كامله في الامم المتحده كما
فعلت الصين
ان سياستنا تركز على التحسين الملموس
لمعيشه الناس في الميدان هذا هو الامر
الاهم بالنسبه للناس تحسن مستوى المعيشه
تحسن مستوى الحريه والازدهار والاغتصاب
لدينا
اهمم
في واشنطن انكم تمارسون ضغط على الامم
المتحده من اجل عدم تحديث اللائحه السوداء
لشركات العامله في المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
ما طبيعه تلك الضغوط
الامم المتحده بشان افضل
[موسيقى]
مع مستوى الامن والحريه والازدهار ونحن
واضحون كل الوضوء
لا يمكنني ان اضيف على ما قالته الحكومه
الامريكيه
سيد عمر هل انت على تواصل مع مسؤولين من
حماس
وبالتالي ليس لدينا اي اي تواصل مباشر
معهم
مصالح
ا يعني من الشعب الفلسطيني
ويها رجال الجيش
الجامعه العربيه في الجزائر ودارت نقاشات
جيده بيننا
والقياده الجزائريه
الدوله الفلسطينيه
للولايات المتحده
ههه الولايات المتحده هي السند الاساسي
لاسرائيل كيف يمكن لواشنطن ان تكون الخصم
والحكم بمعنى اخر كيف توازنون في سياقتكم
بين الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
لا تسعى لتكون الخصم او الحكم نحن بلد في
المنظومه الدوليه الى جانب بلدان اخرى
الدفعه اهداف
ولسنا الحكم
باي طريقه
على
توجهات او مجريات الامور
جميع الشرك في المنطقه مع
القياد الفلسطينيه مع اسرائيل مع الاردن
مع مصر مع الحلفاء الاوروبيين والاخرى في
المنطقه
سفاره امريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
الرئيس ووزير الخارجيه كان واضحين نحن
نرغب باعاده فتح
القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس ولكن ليس لدي اي خبر
اليوم بهذا الشان
مم كنت اسالك عن القصه الشرقيه اذا
كنتمونه همم فتح همم سفاره في القدس
الشرقيه
نعم للوضوء
كان واضحين اي اننا
لدينا رغبه متواصله لاعاده فتحي القنصليه
العامه في
شرقي في القدس الشرقيه ولكن ليس لدي اي
شيء اضيفه اليوم
متى ستتوجه الى المنطقه وما هي اولى
مهمه
القدس ورام الله بشكل متواصل وسواصل
ورحلاته اليها
خلال الاسبوع القادمه
يعني هناك مخرج لي الازمه قريبا في الوقت
الحالي
اعرف ان افاق حل الدولتين والاتفاق اتفاق
السلام تبدو بعيدا ولكننا نحاول تحسين
الوضع في الميدان
ونبذل قصار الجهود لتحقيق الاستقرار ورفع
مستوى المعيشه
[موسيقى]
الامور عليه